tropical storm erie made landfall in
japan's southwestern kyushu region early
on tuesday bringing with it heavy rains
that's left streets and homes underwater
japan's weather agency has issued
advisories for potential landslides and
overflowing rivers
it's a similar situation in china where
some southern provinces are flooded in
the wake of typhoon chava
state media broadcast dramatic video of
a rescuer at sailing across flood waters
to rescue a woman trapped in her car
homes farmland roads and power lines
have been damaged
there are more than 40 houses in the
area the worst affected are aquaculture
farmers is they need electricity to
supply their animals with oxygen we
deployed repair crews to restore power
to the affected facilities as soon as
the rain stopped
heavy rain and floods aren't unusual in
the region at this time of the year
the typhoon season generally lasts from
may to october
but with the climate crisis causing more
extreme weather patterns
scenes like this could become a lot more
common in the future
florence louis al jazeera